have you ever been minding your own
business enjoying the sun when someone
steps in front of you and blocks your
sunlight this is pretty much what
happens during a solar eclipse except on
a planetary scale as earth revolves
around the sun the moon revolves around
earth too once in a while the sun the
moon and earth all line up so the moon's
shadow falls onto earth causing a solar
eclipse during a solar eclipse the moon
blocks the sun's light and energy from
reaching part of earth so how does a
solar eclipse appear from earth well if
you're standing in the center of the
moon's shadow you'd see the moon appear
to completely cover the sun's disk
this is called a total solar eclipse
there are other types of solar eclipses
but we're going to focus on total solar
eclipses in this video
during a total solar eclipse the
outermost layer of the sun's atmosphere
called its corona is visible on a
non-solar eclipse day the corona is
invisible to us because we can't see
past the bright light from the sun's
surface remember to never stare or look
at the sun with your naked eye
binoculars or a telescope looking even
for a few seconds can cause severe and
permanent eye damage just because you
can't look directly at the sun doesn't
mean that you can't enjoy watching a
solar eclipse though you can watch the
eclipse in action through a pinhole
viewer or ultraviolet ray blocking solar
eclipse glasses if you're in the moon
shadow during a total solar eclipse you
might also notice a drop in temperature
on average the temperature drops about
5.5 degrees celsius during a total solar
eclipse this is because the moon blocks
solar energy from reaching earth
total solar eclipses last only a few
minutes this is because the moon is
always revolving around earth as the
moon keeps on moving the sun starts to
reappear around the moon and eventually
the sun returns to its usual round and
sunny self but how is it even possible
for the moon to appear to block the sun
in the first place the sun and the moon
aren't the same size in fact the sun is
so big that 64.3 million moons could fit
inside of it however coincidentally the
sun is far enough away that the moon and
the sun appear to us earthlings to be
the same size in the sky
so when the moon moves between the sun
and earth during a total solar eclipse
it appears from earth to cover the disk
of the sun almost exactly
total solar eclipses like all solar
eclipses happen only during a new moon
which is the only time in the moon's
orbit where the moon is located between
the sun and earth solar eclipses don't
happen every new moon though
most of the time the moon earth and the
sun are not lined up this is because the
plane of the moon's orbit around earth
is at a different angle than the plane
of earth's orbit around the sun this
means that the moon's shadow is usually
too high or too low to hit earth and
cause an eclipse
total solar eclipses won't be visible
from earth in about 600 million years
this is because the moon's orbit is
gradually getting bigger with the moon
moving about four centimeters away from
earth each year
so one day the moon will appear to be
too small in the sky to entirely block
the sun's light
total solar eclipses take place on earth
every 18 months or so but sometimes
they're only visible from the middle of
an ocean or a desert if you're curious
about when the next total solar eclipse
will happen near you look it up online
scientists are able to calculate when
solar eclipses will happen centuries in
advance so you can start planning far
ahead
personally i'll need to travel if i want
to see a total solar eclipse anytime
soon because the next one visible in my
hometown is on september 14 2099